he's gonna come back stronger go cash  but Richard is going to take the win  he's never losing a rook and Bishop  endgame again ever again this is the  final time he'll ever lose the same game  yeah  but Richard report I mean his Domino and  belief that he could win this  very very impressive  trickery as well just the psychology and  there we go after 167 moves you guys  it's over Richard report takes the  quarter-final match he's ready for the  semi-final after what must be I I'm not  100 sure but it could be the longest  Marathon game we've seen on the tour  incredible stuff by Richard report  he must be your hero now David yeah I've  got a new chess Idol and Well Done  Richard you deserve it just for your  perseverance but good cash yeah just he  we're such big fans he's gonna come back